The joe rogan experience,
you know,
I remember he cried after the
Vegas Shooting and he's from Vegas.
Did he cry recently? Was it the
school shooting? Yeah. Yeah,
but that was brutal though.
He's fucking go out with,
was there that night and she was at
the trop and then all the people came
running down into the trop.
Oh, so new year's Eve,
I'm with Vegas shooting people.
They had to stay there for a couple hours.
They had everything under locked down
because they didn't know who had guns and
who did. And they didn't know it
was one person or 50 people. Right.
And she's there. She's
at the trop. And uh,
she got kind of traumatized by it.
So New Year's Eve,
we're walking outside and all of a sudden
she starts shaking and she was having
an anxiety attack, you know,
about being in a crowd.
So I was just fucking are trying to
make her laugh. I said, no, don't,
don't worry about it. And then we're,
you know, fireworks. So she said,
all I really care about is fireworks.
And you took that away from
me because you're selfish
and feelings, you know, but,
but I got her laughing
anyway. The fucking, the,
the volume of them,
it's just,
it seems like every couple months there's
a new one. You remember when Columbine,
we thought this is terrible
and it's won't happen again.
It's like there's so many Nalia, you know,
you get used to it, which has said, yeah,
it's fucking crazy. And I don't
know what the answer is. You know,
I don't know if it's
a tighter gun control.
I don't know if that would stop them
because it would just make it more
difficult to get guns. But
would that be enough? I mean,
but we're not doing anything. Well,
interesting thing. Got to try something.
I don't know what to do.
I mean,
and there's also the number of people
that are on psychiatric medications.
It's fucking crazy. Well, I think that
for the [inaudible] or whatever they are,
they shouldn't be sold. They shouldn't be.
I mean, I, we didn't really need that to,
to kill a pheasant. It's
not a, a hunting gun really.
You're the guy who designed them, said
he it was w we made it for war. Yeah.
The real real guns for hunting are
usually usually bolt action rifles,
which means you have a,
around,
you have usually two or
three in the magazine.
You have a couple or one in the
chamber. You put it in there, cheeky,
lock it in place,
the clamp it down and you fire a shot
and then you have to bolt it again.
You have to use the, the action again. The
shell pops out and another one goes in,
bolt that down and then you get
another shot. It's a very slow thing.
It takes a couple of second
musket. Whereas these ais,
you're like tack, tack, tack,
tack tack or with the bump stocks.
They apparently the president wants a
ban bump stocks with a bump. Stock is,
Oh yeah.
It's a stock where you pull back on it
and apparently you push forward and pull
back at the same time. Uh,
I might be fucking this up,
but the thing is the stock makes the, the
trigger go like that, that, that, that,
that, that, that, that, that where
it's almost like an automatic weapon.
And Trump just decided to ban those.
And there's a lot of people that are
up in arms about him banning those,
like these, the gun rights. People
don't want to lose anything.
They don't want to lose any rights.
Right?
They don't want to lose any
fucking crazy ass weapons.
They think that any slip is,
uh,
is eventually going to lead to
them getting their guns taken away.
Like I follow a bunch of NRA people and
gone people on Twitter and Instagram
take their guns away. They think they
are, they think they are. I mean,
I agree with you. I don't think
that's ever going to come to that,
but the idea that tighter
regulation, um, is bad.
I don't think that's true. I
think, uh, I think first of all,
you should have to go through
some sort of examination.
If you can go through an exam,
you don't,
you can't drive a fucking car unless
you prove that you know how to operate a
car. Like someone has to be there with
you. That's an expert. So driving expert,
who watches you? They watch.
Make sure you know what to do.
What do you do here at this light?
Do you know how to hit the brakes?
Do you stop perfectly look left and right
before you turn all that shit is super
important. If you want to
drive, how the fuck is it?
Not Super important if you
operate a goddamn firearm.
I know, I don't understand.
I like the kid who bought the,
I think the kid who did the, uh,
the latest shooting in Florida,
I think it was, if I'm a have,
I'm putting two stories together,
I don't know.
But apparently he was under age and had
fake id and still was able to buy it.
I don't know. I didn't read that story.
That'd be, you know, I avoided the story.
I saw the kid's face and I saw
the, it's, it's fucking insane.
And then you hear all the stories about
kids that were saying that they knew
that this kid was going to be a
school shooter anyway. They, they,
they were saying in, in the past.
And then one of the things he wrote,
he wrote it on Facebook or something
that he wants to be a professional school
shooter.
And then two years later and
he got visited by the FBI,
the FBI actually checked this fucking
kid out. Talk to him about him, the side,
he wasn't a threat. How do you decide
someone's a threat or not a threat? Well,
if you're talking to them, they're
a threat. I mean, they may be,
I can't talk to everybody, but I, I would,
I would be suspicious of anyone that it
took that much energy to go find out.
What, how did they find them? Why would
they, why would they would question him?
Yeah. Um, I think people were saying
that he's a fucking psychopath. Yeah.
It hurts.
It's just sad.
It's just fucking sad that it's
sad that anyone could do that.
It's sad that anyone would be hurting
and so fucked up that you could take a
child. Imagine you have a kid, right? You
got a little dom Irrera little tiny baby,
and he's just a cute little fella, little
tiny baby, and they don't know anything.
They didn't tickle him.
And then from there one day that
becomes as to a school shooter,
Oh my God. That's what people have
to take into consideration. This boy,
this 19 year old boy who did that
was a baby at one point in time.
He's a failed process of failed product.
Yeah.